hey there folks continuing with fun  little kind of educational videos about  lgbtqia plus topics for  pride month um i just want to talk about  a little bit of etiquette when dealing  with  anyone who has in some way transitioned  to a new  point in their life new pronouns  possibly a new name now that could be a  trans man a trans woman someone  non-binary  agender by gender basically anything  where the identifiers they use both  their name and or their pronouns are not  what they have  always used across their life now i've  addressed this before in full length  videos but  just a quick reminder here you do not  refer  to them in the past by anything other  than their current  name and pronoun preferences even if you  are referring to a point in time  prior to their using those you can  instigate dysphoria you can cause a lot  of confusion frankly it's just kind of  rude  so use their current names even when  talking about the past